[Music]
[Applause]
Ross Tucker Westwood One CBS Sports NFL
and college football analyst and the
host of the Ross Tucker football podcast
also social media at Ros Tucker NFL he
was on the call for the Giants and the
bills on Westwood one last night how do
you feel if you're the Buffalo Bills
today
Ross I think you feel very very relieved
Dan because the Giants are down at the
one yard line really we could talk about
the end of the first half for the whole
segment but then one yard line at the
end of the game they have a couple
opportunities there can you I mean I was
in the stadium obviously can you imagine
if Waller catches that or maybe they
throw a pass interference penalty Giants
get another play and then they score the
just the air that would have went out of
that Stadium there's a huge huge
difference between being four- two and
three and three I think they feel very
very relieved and thankful that they
escaped with a win the commissioner was
talking about maybe London hosting a
Super Bowl in the foreseeable future um
Are we more likely to have a team in
London first or a Super Bowl in
London I think probably a Super Bowl
actually I think there's a lot of
logistical issues with putting a team
over there I think they're kind of
Dipping their toes in the water a little
bit with having the Jags play
back-to-back games over there would you
want to play in
London as a player yeah absolutely Dan
but I am the exception not the rule
right so like my wife and I have talked
about that I would have loved that I
mean we have the perspective of it's a
really short time in your life maybe
it's a two-year deal three-year deal for
me it was a lot of
oneye oneyear situations so to be over
there heck yeah man I mean when I played
for the Patriots in the off season my
wife and I every week and we went to
Cape cot or Martha's Vineyard n Tucket
it was awesome right we were in our 20s
it was fabulous I would have loved to
have played for London have that
International experience for a couple
years but to be fair Dan most guys are
not like me most guys do not have that
same perspective most guys have no
interest in playing or living overseas
how do you think the fans would react to
a Super Bowl in
London I think there'd be a lot of uh
negativity here in the States because of
the belief that hey why would there be a
game in London when there's never been
one in Chicago when there's never been
one in Philadelphia I think you would
probably get
a lot of that reaction and I understand
that but I I'll say this Dan I'm totally
in favor of it and I'll tell you why you
guys know how I feel about football like
I love it like I I I love it more than
almost anything other than my family
think about all of the kids around the
world that play soccer and think that
that's like the most fun sport to play I
mean think about that now I think soccer
is great I played soccer Dan when I was
like six years old till I was 11 it's a
fun sport but once you put a helmet and
shoulder pads on and run into another
kid and knock him over that's the
greatest feeling ever you don't ever
want to go kick a soccer ball again the
rest of your life once you I don't know
anybody that went played soccer then
played football then went back to soccer
so anything we can do internationally to
spread the game I am big time Big Time
in favor of because I want more people
internationally to get a chance to play
heck I did the Vanderbilt Georgia game
for CBS on Saturday three of
Vanderbilt's defensive linemen are from
Europe one's from the UK two from
Germany I think it's awesome they are
doing a good job of growing the game
internationally yeah I just wonder what
the reaction why would the commissioner
bring this up like there's no you know
coincidence I mean he doesn't do throwi
inss and know hey I'm just uh talking
off the cuff here why is the
commissioner bringing up the possibility
of a Super Bowl in
London I think two two reasons number
one to gauge the feedback right so let's
say you talk about it today people call
in and they're Furious about it I think
they just want to know just how bad it
would be if they ever elected to make
that decision the other thing is I think
it generates even more interest
internationally about it right I'm sure
that got picked up all over Europe that
the commit Mally the NFL says the
biggest sporting event in America might
get exported to Europe you know and
that's exactly what he was probably
going for I think it's smart we're
talking to Ross Tucker Westwood One CBS
sports analyst what about buffalo
getting a
superb well they're getting a new
stadium that's why I wonder yeah you
build a stadium it's kind of it's kind
of been a a quidd pro quo there Dan
where it's like all right you guys give
us the Public Funding for the new
stadium we'll give you one Super Bowl
now I I know they don't like the idea of
weather impacting the game but
then that doesn't bother me at all first
of all I love football in weather like
that and secondly could it be worse than
the Chiefs and the Eagles sliding all
over the place in the in the grass or
whatever they were calling that out in
Arizona now I'll say this
you know I went to the Minnesota Super
Bowl where the Eagles won and they beat
the Patriots and I'm glad Minnesota got
a Super Bowl for the all the people that
come to the game it is nicer if you're
in nice weather I mean seeing you guys
last year in Arizona at that ballpark
you guys are at that's better than you
know freezing our butts off in Minnesota
like that's objectively better worst
loss of the
weekend by who oh well
I think on the NFL side maybe the Eagles
just because you know the Niners had
already lost so it was like the eagles
had that chance to get that game up on
them they were up by two scores against
Zack Wilson and the Jets and to go minus
four in turnover ratio but I'm gonna
give you a different one Dan I actually
think the worst loss the weekend was the
Colorado Buffalo Friday night I mean
because it was the only game on
they're up 29 nothing at halftime
there's so much Buzz around them and
because everybody went to bed at
halftime Dan yeah it was like so so did
Colorado I I know I know but it was so
funny because it was like the thing we
everybody had the exact same reaction
when they woke up Saturday morning like
wait what they
lost it like it continued the
conversation for all of Saturday morning
until the next game started and So what
had been sort of a feel-good story is
now okay now they've lost however many
games and now they have a really bad
loss on their record best win of the
weekend Cleveland Browns Cleveland
Browns yeah I mean first of all they
have the best defense in the NFL right
now and I I don't know that I can
remember another unit or a side of the
ball having a total 180 damn they were
terrible on defense last year like real
real bad and now they got the best
defense in the NFL right now with the
way they're playing or certainly one of
the two or three best to win a game
without Watson to stay in the mix this
at least lets them it's interesting too
because I think the guys in Cleveland
and in New York with the Jets are both
kind of on the hot seat I think they
both need to win this year so to win the
way in which they did against undefeated
teams but I'll say Cleveland just
because the ners that have been on so
much of a role the Browns have allowed
just over a thousand yards the fewest by
any team through the first five games of
a season since the 1971 Baltimore Colts
wow yeah yeah pretty crazy there yeah I
didn't know that stat I was almost
thinking well maybe the Niners defense
or no I guess statistically because I
knew Baltimore had a pretty decent game
against them but that is very very
impressive I wonder if by the end of the
year we'll be talking about Jim Schwarz
getting a second chance to be a head
coach you know some guys just aren't
head coaches you know this like all of
those New England Patriot assistant
coaches I mean that that doesn't mean
you should be a head coach um and you
know what Dan yeah it's a different job
yes it's a very different job and and
I'm not saying this like fritzy is great
at what he does good Paul's great at
what he does SE Marvin all but like just
because fritzy the best guest Booker out
there doesn't mean he could go in your
chair I mean that'd be amazing I would
love to see I would definitely watch or
listen to the whole episode if that
happen but that doesn't mean like
doesn't mean someone else be make it
like the Todd Fritz show and have him be
doing it as much as everybody knows I
love him maybe one of these days Todd
sits here and I'll sit over where Todd
does that would be amaz and so he can
say thank you Dan thank you D that would
be that would be uh bigger game tonight
for the Cowboys or the
Chargers I would say Cowboys um they
they can't go to three and three and
lose back-to-back games like this I mean
with with the the Visions they have
because then they'll still be two games
behind the Philadelphia Eagles they got
to bounce back after that Niners
performance they have to so I'll say
I'll say for the Cowboys but maybe
that's just because they're the Cowboys
and we all talk about them so much
always good to talk to you uh what games
do you have this upcoming weekend yeah
likewise uh Dan just some action on
Saturday I'm driving to Athens Ohio
never been there in my life Western
Michigan at Ohio you on Saturday on CBS
Sports Network and you know what I love
it just as much as Georgia Vandy on CBS
or the bills and the Giants last night
like I love it for all the reasons I
love it safe travels thanks man all
right that's Ross Tucker a Ross Tucker
football podcast and available on social
media at Ros Tucker NFL